so synthetic biology is in a way a very
new kind of science and not so new in
another way in the late 1960s scientists
were figuring out so the basic molecular
workings of life and they were
understanding it's so well particularly
in little organisms like e.coli bacteria
that they said you know we might be able
to actually engineer living things and
so the first really spectacular example
of that was with e.coli what scientists
did was take a gene for insulin for
human insulin the kind of insulin we
make in our own bodies and inserting
that into the coli and so now you have
ecoli with this gene actually churning
out human insulin and so a lot of
diabetics today actually get their
insulin from ecoli it doesn't say e coli
on box but that's where it comes from so
that went by the name of genetic
engineering and basically gave rise to
the whole biotechnology industry which
is about an 80 billion dollar industry
today so more recently scientists have
said maybe we can take this further
rather than just sticking one or two or
three genes into a host microbe for
example you know maybe we can tailor our
entire networks of genes so that can do
really sophisticated new things and so
what they're trying to do is they're
trying to think about ecoli or any other
microbe or cell as a kind of a network
in the same way that you could think of
the circuits and a cell phone in the
network and so they just take a the
point of view of an engineer and I just
say I'm going to rearrange this network
i'm going to plug in new units and make
this network look differently and do new
things things that you might never
imagine living things doing before right
now
static biology is still in kind of the
science fair stage I would call it and
actually if you go to MIT every year
they have a contest for students so
these undergraduates get together and
they say hey wouldn't it be cool if for
example we could make ecoli flash in
these pretty colors let's make eco light
it gives off rainbows of colors or let's
make ecoli that that gives off the the
odor of spearmint because normally you
call I smells pretty nasty so let's make
the nice smelling e.coli and it takes
undergraduates a few weeks in the summer
to do just that which is amazing and a
little scary that even a 18 year old has
the power to transform life in ways it
has never been transformed before the
reason that they can do this all is
because there are now these these online
databases of genes and they're basically
laid out kind of like you would look in
a catalog of circuit parts for example
and you can say oh I want that I want
that I want that and I'm going to plug
them together to make them do whatever
it is I want them to do now we're going
to go very rapidly from the science fair
stage to the industrial stage I mean
there's a huge amount of investment in
synthetic biology now one of the really
spectacular possible advances is using
ecoli or maybe yeast to make medicine
for malaria there's a very effective
medicine from malaria that comes from a
plant called a wormwood plant which
normally grows in in Asia the problem
there is that it's hard to raise the
plant and then isolate this this drug
from it called Artemis Minh it's
expensive and it's slow and it keeps the
price pretty high so the hope is that
scientists at the University of
California Berkeley are going to be able
to put
program yeast by just plugging in genes
from different kinds of plants to turn
out a precursor of Artemis in huge
amounts and then you can just take that
and just refine it a little bit and boom
you've got incredibly cheap drugs from
malaria which you know you could
theoretically distribute around the
world or actually you could just take
these yeast themselves and set up tanks
of them in different parts of the world
so you could have them churning out this
medicine on site